this is why my ancestors need to the
city
hi there i'm dan baird head instructor
for california survival school and i
teach people how to survive in extreme
locations all over the world i'm here
today to see if these buzzfeed creators
have survival skills like the characters
in amazon prime videos the wilds the
wilds is about a group of stranded
teenage girls who unravel the mystery
behind their role in a grand social
experiment discovering a much larger
conspiracy that pits them against a
group of teenage boys in our version
curly joyce tucker and lindsey will have
to follow survival instructions found on
scrolls that are scattered throughout
the wilderness hi my name is joyce and
everything about nature scares me hi my
name is tucker and what i lack in
survival skills i make up for
in fashion hi my name is lindsay and i
really don't want to be here what's up
guys my name is curly and i was born in
hollywood so i was born in the wild i'm
ready what the creators don't know is
that there's a little twist to today's
challenges
we're gonna be conducting a little bit
of a
social experiment we want to see what
the bigger motivator is for people
fear
or money
i've separated the creators into two
teams curly and joyce tucker and lindsey
i'm gonna tell curly and joyce that if
they finish first they win a huge cash
prize you know i'm excited for the cash
i'm excited for the cash the cash really
motivates you know what if we win i'm
gonna take her out to dinner if we i'll
take you out to dinner you can get
whatever you want you can get whatever
you
it's gonna be so much fun and i'll tell
lindsey and tucker that if they lose
they're spending the night right here in
the woods
neither of us want to stay overnight not
at all i'm coming in so confident my
hypothesis here is that fear is going to
be the bigger motivating factor let's
see if that makes a difference in how
they perform
teams are you ready to see
if you can survive out of the wild
[Applause]
thank you
your map will give you the locations for
each challenge and when you arrive
you'll find further instructions read
them carefully and think strategically
you guys have maps you guys have
compasses now it's up to you and your
team to navigate and find your gear and
achieve your objectives go
i'm going
it's good to be out here in nature all
right we're gonna head towards that hill
with the yellow
flowers but i can't find a pin because
it's just a bunch of trees they all look
the same can we look at one flower maybe
i think this is the way to go and the
compass literally says curly it says
it's that way
yeah come this is this way oh it doesn't
you just stuck the freaking cup in i'm
not gonna lie i'm thirsty
i should have brought water me too oh my
gosh it's like survival dan said wing it
didn't you really say that yes he did
this should go this way no no where's
the compass oh
damn that's what you're trying to fight
don't hate me but
i've re i've realigned and we actually
have to go that way i think we actually
made it oh dope we did it
okay okay we got our supplies and
backpacks
in your first challenge you can pick
five items and choose carefully because
you'll need to pick tools and supplies
that will not only get you through the
nights but also get you through the next
two challenges through the night
i thought we were just gonna get a check
i believe we put our number at 12 out of
10 confidence
that has significantly dropped i do not
feel confident anymore
are you all not hearing this i'm about
to walk away and say good night
that sounds like a moose did you hear
that i thought it was my stomach
so these are the items that me and curly
decided on the water filtration system
the first aid kit if we're staying
overnight which i don't want to then we
need to like be prepared you know
honestly i kind of agree the shovel
the walking sticks and the knife okay
should we use them honestly yeah i think
that might be good
we're gonna go to the next challenge we
have warmth blanket knives water
filtration flashlight
a rope that's five binoculars i mean
cute
don't eat it okay we need to go because
i do not let's get out of here live here
and this challenge you'll need to
construct a shelter this is why my
ancestors moved to the city
all right you need to check it out curly
this shelter looks so dope you think
this will protect us from rain
or like coyotes or
mob cats
our inner demons
there's a giant spider on me
get out
let's just start yeah
as we get towards the end
i'm getting more and more scared because
i do not want to sleep here
my confidence level yes
a two if we were really in the wilds
would this suffice a girl look around we
really are in the wilds right now i mean
what more can we add this is crazy
grab it grabber gabby no they're coming
little haters the last challenge is the
most important finding fresh water you
need enough water to fill your canteens
the team that fills both of their
canteens with water then drinks all of
it wins i don't know kind of sounds like
a lose-lose situation to me to be honest
yeah they're little tadpoles in here
like you can see things moving around oh
my god okay we know there's no time to
waste i don't think there's not much
water you gotta feel it
oh i'm like seeing sticks and stuff okay
okay
this is nasty this looks like spotless
clean water
wow look at that
here do you want to
put no
you know what no
oh there we go it's clear what whoa
look at that
i'm thinking i'm uh adult enough to
admit when not to drink dukey water
we got a chug okay you drink half water
in half
yes
huh
no i'm gonna try i'm gonna try i want to
try it oh no
i don't
know all right you guys both completed
challenges but i still have to pick a
winner
the team that drank the most water won
[Applause]
but here's the deal there's no prize
there's nobody on the line and no one
has to sleep here tonight we wanted to
see what the bigger motivator would be
money or fear the fear team won
so obviously fear was the bigger
motivator i feel like we were hoodwinked
we were hoodwinked but at the same time
i do feel like i was more motivated
because i was actually scared of staying
out here absolutely but you know what i
think this is a win-win for everyone
because they didn't win and we don't
have to stay here yay
do we think that we could survive in
prime videos of the wild
no no
i could never
survive on prime videos of the wild i
couldn't even survive in this state park
[Music]
you